الجميع يشتكي من اسعار تذاكر الطيران
الملتهبه اعتقد كلنا من عالم هذا الموضوع
وسبب يكمن في قله عدد الطائرات بحسب دراسه
اجرتها شركه التامين الالمانيه اللاينز
تريد
فلنصنعون يتعافون ببطء من الركود في
عمليات التسليم في عام 2020 ولن يصلوا الى
مستوى ما قبل الازمه العالميه البالغ نحو
1600 طائره ركاب جديده في العام الحالي
ايضا طبعا هنا مشاهدينا نذكر انه اسعار
التذاكر بين الولايات المتحده واوروبا
ارتفع معدل ارتفعت بالفعل بمعدل
23% خلال عام طبعا هي اصلا بتكون مرتفعه
اكثر بكثير من السفر في نفس في نفس
المنطقه او الاقليم و 23% هي نسبه عاليه
بالفعل ويتوقعون المزيد ايضا من ارتفاعات
بنهايه العام بسبب قله الطائرات
العام
احنا بنستنى شوي لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات